Men are making choices for us,
women about birth control,
abortion, healthcare, everything. And we,
we can't even have a say
on it cause he won't even,
I have my non feminists in the left
spotlights that my feminist in the right
spotlight,
the feminist movement has changed
from its original definition.
Yeah.
Okay.
The reason why I hesitated is because
I started to think about who is most
served by mainstream feminism.
I don't personally think that that
has changed. I think that white,
heterosexual,
cisgendered women are most
served by mainstream feminism.
When I heard the definition of feminist
rate, I was like, yeah, I'm a feminist.
Like yeah, you know, I believe in
equality of the sexes. Of course they do.
But it changed.
The more that I researched the movement,
the more that I saw how
mainstream media portrayed it.
And to me it's like there's a lot
of issues with that happen to men in
disproportionate amounts that are
always overlooked that you know,
no one talks about the suicide rate.
No one talks about the
homelessness rate for men.
And it sucks because if you're whole
movement is based around equality of the
sexes, right. And to make sure both sexes
are equal, then that covers the whole,
the whole spectrum, right? It's
not just one sex, it's equality.
The title of feminist
inherently excludes men.
Interesting.
But the definition doesn't it?
Male privilege is real.
It's not lost on me.
How many more men are in academia and
in higher education are women are called
more often to put their careers on hold,
um,
in order to have children or
for whatever other reasons.
That's just kind of the way I see it
manifesting most in my life is just seeing
how hard it is to be an intellectual
woman. Um, and academia.
My name is faith and I am not a feminist.
I am a strong woman and I
was raised by strong women,
but I cannot get behind a few of the core
ideals of what it often means to be a
feminist.
So I do not identify as one.
My mother is a teacher.
She has her master's.
She's as years and years of experience
and yet her place within the school,
her place within,
um,
as far as like authority over
students is not the same as a man.
And I think that's an inequality that,
um,
I've just been shown from my
mother who comes home and says,
you know,
I just had the worst day of work because
I was uncomfortable the entire time.
Or I had a strange experience with a male
student who just like would not listen
to a word I said.
It wasn't connecting.
And it wasn't until I brought in the
vice principal who was male or another
teacher who was mental. That things
can be kind of squashed and covered.
Yeah.
Just growing up,
I would say that overall or our school
systems are more geared towards women.
There's more female teachers, and that's
how our children aren't raised. You know,
the,
the thing is that you were alluding to,
your mom has to deal with
those difficulties that a
man would not have to deal
with.
Men have to deal with a
lot of difficulties that
most women wouldn't have to
deal with and we do benefit from
certain privileges. But so to women,
I think you considered it
a privilege that women,
there are more women in
the teaching profession,
but you should also consider that
other options weren't necessarily or
historically available to women
because they were considered to be more
nurturing. A lot of women
were pushed into that field.
Still women are choosing these majors
and choosing their region of study,
whereas men are tending to
choose higher paying majors.
They're choosing more to go into stem
fields and such like that and reaping the
financial benefits while women are also
reaping their own happiness benefits of
going into a field that they enjoy.
If I were born the opposite sex,
my life would be easier.
I started to walk over just thinking
inherently the privileges that men in the
society have and how they're
able to navigate far easier and,
and all of that stuff.
And then I thought what it would be
like to be a black man in this society.
And, um, I don't know that
it would be any easier.
I am first generation Mexican American.
I have cheap Mexican parents.
Um,
if I were to be born a male Mexican,
it'd be so much easier
for just that group.
I tried to break off from
those stereotypes of Melanie,
get the table ready for
dinner. Uh, excuse me.
I have two brothers that can do
the exact same thing. You know,
why can't they do it?
Why do I have to do it?
My name is Melanie Valdez and
I am on the feminist side.
I had an incident where I was sexually
assaulted and that changed my whole
perspective.
If I was born,
any other thing than I
am,
I would have to struggle differently than
I have already struggled and you know,
compare it to some people and you know,
minorities or some people that are white,
some people that are white
of struggle more than me.
There's always a positive and a
negative that you're born with.
And it's how you utilize
that and get over it.
That I think is important rather than
focusing on if I was born this or if I was
born.
That
I think it is kind of what we make of
it and I'd almost say that to to want to
be anything different than what we are
is possibly even defeating the purpose of
the feminist movement.
A big part of feminism is telling
women that they're worth it already.
That there are already enough.
I have a little sister,
I have friends who were told by their,
by their father,
by their older brother that you are
enough and other don't whenever they want
because they were told they could.
They weren't given the opportunity from
the beginning and they weren't told,
well if you are a man you
could no, no, no, no, no.
They were told you are a woman and
you can because of who you are.
Not sure that having a community
that affirms who you are is enough.
If the society and the structure and the
laws and the policies that govern tell
you otherwise. My parents told me
I could do whatever I want to do.
And so I went to law school and
I'm an attorney and I write,
but I don't make as much as my,
my coworker who does the exact same thing
and who I'm probably a more qualified
then
from the statistics that I read, there was
no wage gap. Those in earnings. Yes. Yes.
Generally it's your understanding that
there is no wage gap between men and
women. Yes. There's that. Yeah.
Different positions, uh, different, uh,
different schooling can also be a factor.
You can have the same degree but from
two different schools and they'll pay
someone from the better school.
Different, uh, how the interviews go.
Even negotiable, you know, entry salaries.
Why then are women choosing
jobs that pay less a culture?
Men and women need to work
together to create equality.
I think one of the reasons that I can
take issue with certain types of feminism
is it does come across as anti man.
Sometimes it comes across as
it's your fault. You know,
if I go to the women's March and I see
signs that say smash the Patriarchy and
like our p word bites
back and stuff like that,
that's as much as that speaking against
an oppressive top culture that's
speaking to all men.
And I don't see that as helpful.
Well, I think all men benefit
from patriarchy. I mean,
you need to acknowledge
your privilege first.
If people could hear that about themselves
and not be defensive,
I think that we could probably push
the needle forward a lot faster.
Um,
something that plagues the feminist
movement is that there's this idea that in
order to, um, gain equal footing,
the other side has to be
emasculated or has to be, um,
dropped down and it's not, this
is empire. You know what I mean?
Just cause I get a slice doesn't mean
you get, you get, you get less, right.
Yeah.
Advocating for women's rights doesn't
infringe upon men's rights. Right.
You know,
first and second wave feminism were very
clear in the very particular thing is
that they were trying to accomplish.
You had first wave feminism,
which was very clearly, you're
trying to get the right to vote. Um,
second wave feminism right after,
like World War II and such,
helping women progressing
in the workplace and such.
And now I see third wave feminism and it
is a broken apart can be lost movement
that goes in so many directions, has so
many extra qualifiers. And I think about,
um,
I was talking to one of my friends who
went to the women's march with a pro life
feminist group and she
said on multiple accounts,
they were asked to leave because that's
not why the women's march was happening
and did they were,
they were against the movement.
And so you have all these
different types of, of feminism.
There doesn't seem to be a
clear center and a clear desire.
And I hear people call themselves
feminists for all different reasons.
And with some of them I would agree and
I would call myself a feminist for those
reasons.
But because it's so all over the place,
I just can't call myself a feminist.
If feminists can make a concise,
uh,
push towards one issue together,
what I would I be willing to join if I
agreed with the point? Yes. Okay. If I,
if I agreed with what the
movement was going for, yes, yes.
If it's just not sure that I'm concerned
whether or not you want to join as it
would end, it was about not part of the
issue, but that's segregating Jen. That's,
that's segregating genders.
If you're saying that you don't care about
my opinion as a man that goes against
everything.
The photos here reshaping and forming
my feminism in a way that is digestible
for you as a man.
So what's the current one message?
The definition of feminism
across the board is the social,
political and economic
equality of the sexes. Yes.
Why are we only talking about
the female inequalities?
Why aren't we talking about the mail?
And you call,
you do not have the same experience.
We do not.
You are not oppressed in
the same ways that I am. No.
And I'm sure you're not oppressed
in the same ways that I am.
More of our world leaders should be women.
Let's talk about um, for
like this like abortion. Um,
those who signed the bill in the room
with Trump, they were all white men.
I did not see a single woman.
Does it matter if it's a white woman?
I did not take a single woman in there.
So those
men are making choices for us.
Women about birth control,
abortion, healthcare, everything. And we,
we can't even have a say on it
cause they won't even hear us.
I don't view it as we should
have more women in office.
I view it as we should have the
most qualified people in office.
If you have an issue with, you know,
the bill being signed by white men,
I believe that voting for Congress,
people that are women or you know,
whoever you review and believe
are the most qualified,
we'll put those people in power.
If we are talking about the last election,
I believe that the most
qualified candidate did not win.
People need to really consider
what role gender played in that.
Just logically the people that they're
representing are both men and women.
So the people representing
us should be men and women.
And we'd be really hard for me to ever
understand why people wouldn't think that
there should be more women in leadership.
I love women.
I love being a woman. I love strong
women. I was raised by strong women.
I don't agree with all of the
things that are traditionally, um,
included in feminist beliefs.
Like I have a different view
on abortion then you guys.
So that's a big deal for me. That's one
of the most important things to me. Um,
I'm a Christian and that's just one of
my beliefs. So that's kind of for me,
that's one of the driving forces.
Why I don't identify as a feminist
to divided into two teams gender wise is,
is not spartan.
It's not often what we do,
but it is sometimes.
And how do we avoid that and
how do we avoid that separation?
How do we make it a collective effort?
Even though I'm a conservative
white man and you know,
there are different views than me and I
don't want to force you to agree with me.
Um, I don't want to change
your mind in that way,
but I want to see how I can still work
with you fully and be on your team and
you can be on mine as we disagree.
Agreeably
thank you everyone for probably the
most respectful middle ground I've ever
seen.
Hey guys,
this is Jason from jubilee.
Thank you so much for watching
another episode of middle ground.
We hope you enjoyed it.
As always,
please let us know in the comments
below what your thoughts are,
as well as if you've got any suggestions
for any new episodes. Believe it or not,
we do read all of your comments,
so thank you. As always,
please click here for more videos.
Click here to subscribe and we'll see.